después de que el anime de dragon ball
super terminar hace poco más de tres
años con una de sus sagas más
ridículamente divertidas su historia del
manga continúa avanzando comenzando
inmediatamente el arco del prisionero
galáctico todo el arco demoró para los
del barrio y a la [ __ ] contra toda
proyección aparente esta saga resultó
ser excelente y muy entretenida teniendo
grandes peleas un argumento mucho mejor
a lo antes visto en super y finalmente
un verdadero villano
para los que no recuerden la saga o no
la hayan visto les voy a hacer un
pequeño resumen el torneo universal
termina y conocemos a moro una cabra
intergaláctica otra amadísima ancestral
que pelea un par de veces contra los
guerreros zetas y la mayoría de veces
muro los hace [ __ ] hasta que goku a
que vaya arengan usar su sano y le gana
ya está
esta historia pasar de todos resulta ser
una de las mejores sagas que ha tenido
ahora con ball super le faltó un poco de
androide 21 me gustó pero está bien ya
hablando en serio la verdad es que creo
que a todos nos sorprendió lo buena que
resultó siendo la historia de moró pues
recupera un poco de la esencia de dragon
ball z es decir donde todo lo que quiere
ser una historia de dragon ball buena
historia un buen villano y grandes
peleas consell es recontra mamá hicimos
no te puedes quejar así que hoy decide
analizar las cosas buenas y malas que
hicieron de la sangre el prisionero
galáctico una saga digna de estar en
dragon ball
como mencioné hace ya un tiempo en el
vídeo que hice acerca de dragon ball
super algo que se echaba de menos en la
serie era un buen villano pues de los
800 mil millones de personajes con los
que goku y vegeta se agarraron a
madrazos el super el único villano real
fuerza mazo pero ahora con la cabra loca
tenemos finalmente a un nuevo personaje
al cual llamar villano pues moro tiene
muchas cosas que lo convierten en un
gran antagonista para esta saga para
comenzar tiene un gran diseño que lo
hace ver imponente sí es cierto que por
lo menos en lo personal su diseño la
parte final del manga se volvió un poco
más genérico me gusta más cómo se había
el comienzo de la historia pero en
general que un aspecto que nos separa de
los demás antagonistas que han tenido un
súper tiene una buena historia y
trasfondo que nos da la oportunidad
desde el comienzo de la historia de
conocer más al personaje es cruel y
brutal y no le importa asesinar quien se
cruce en su camino y sobre todo lo que
más me gusta de moró es que es fuerte
pero su fuerza no se basa en un guión
hace por ejemplo jiren que es uno de los
personajes más rotos de la historia ha
aparecido de la nada y una resultó que a
base de bailar cumbia y el poder del
guión el tipo era casi más fuerte que
todos a lo largo de ocho universos
desde el principio se nos dice que es
fuerte sí pero su fuerza va aumentando a
medida que avanza la serie no sólo
aparece de un momento a otro con
músculos en los músculos que él avanza
como personaje y su fuerza aumenta como
consecuencia de este progreso además
otra cosa que me pareció genial es que
lo que lo hace aterrador no es su fuerza
física o que pueda dar puños con los
ojos lo que hace a moreau tan difícil de
derrotar son sus habilidades su magia
que le permite arrebatarle la energía a
sus oponentes esto está de [ __ ] madre
porque en dragon ball super nos
acostumbramos a que todo se basa en
quién golpea más fuerte pero con moreau
y sus habilidades causaron que la fuerza
bruta no funcionará para nada y
obligaron a la serie y a sus personajes
a avanzar de maneras distintas es por
esto y más que moró funciona tan bien
como antagonista pues es un personaje
mucho mejor construido y más complejo
que hace avanzar a la historia cada vez
más lejos y de una manera que hace
interesante verlo y pensar en qué será
lo próximo que hará
a pesar de que en esta saga lograron
solucionar o por lo menos reducir la
mayoría de los problemas de la serie aún
están presentes en algunas partes de la
historia como claro ejemplo está el
hecho de que recurren mucho a la
nostalgia dándonos escenas que parecen
copias exactas de lo que ya hemos visto
en otras sagas desde goku dándole una
semilla al ermitaño amor o hasta el
momento en el que goku alcance el ultra
instinto perfecto estas escenas no están
mal ni mucho menos pero sería mejor
crear nuevos momentos icónicos de aragón
ball en vez de copiar los que ya hay
las sagas anteriores de dragon ball
super han dejado la barra bastante baja
con respecto al argumento de sus
historias la mayoría de sus sagas tratan
básicamente de o encontramos a un tipo
malo vamos a romperle su madre
pero con este nuevo arco por lo menos la
historia es tomó la molestia de dar
vueltas y crear cada vez más situaciones
que hacían de cada capítulo algo
realmente interesante de ver aquí no
solamente pelean con alguien hasta que
el que tenga los músculos más marcados
gane sino que la historia cada vez logra
complicarse más crea nuevos conflictos y
soluciones por encontrar que logra darle
tanto más profundidad a su historia y el
argumento que están tratando de
presentar cómo mantener a la audiencia
interesada sobre lo que pasará en el
próximo capítulo y esto lo refuerza
muchísimo dándole una gran importancia
al desarrollo de sus personajes se
encontrará ese momento en el que coco
demostró seguir siendo lo imbécil más
grande de los dos universos al darle una
semilla del ermitaño a la persona que
dos minutos antes le hizo un fatality y
les estaba partiendo la madre a todos
sus amigos si eso nunca pasó se
encontrar ese momento los personajes en
esta saga demuestran una gran evolución
miremos a vegueta por ejemplo tan pronto
llegan a miku seguir vegueta se nota
realmente arrepentido por haber
asesinado a tantos seres mientras estaba
en el ejército de freezer y ahora busca
protegerlos a todos en una oportunidad
de redimir sus actos en sus progresos
pero además de eso vegueta perdieron su
primera pelea contra moro ambos
demostraron bastante madurez al aceptar
que moro era un oponente al que no
podían derrotar aún y aunque ambos
siempre al internar solamente buscan
elevar su poder y ponerse más mamados
esta vez decidieron tomar un camino
diferente enfocando su entrenamiento no
en fuerza sino en aprender y mejorar
técnicas que serían eficaces contra un
enemigo con el cual la fuerza bruta no
funciona en el caso de goku mejorando
nuestra instinto y vegueta aprendiendo
su nueva técnica con los hiedra
nuevamente progreso incluso la serie
demostró un gran desarrollo y personaje
con virus un personaje nuevo que resultó
ser muy complejo e interesante llegando
a sacrificarse por sus ideales todas
estas cosas demuestran lo mucho que han
crecido los personajes y que a pesar de
que la serie trata de puños en la cara
esto no evita que los personajes
demuestren la evolución que han tenido a
lo largo de los años
[Música]
este es bastante simple el diseño de
arte los dibujos y en general todo se ve
genial toyota no nos mostró en esta saga
lo mucho que ha crecido como dibujante
dándonos unas páginas tienes de dibujos
e ilustraciones geniales es decir
proyectado siempre ha dibujado muy bien
pero en este arco se nota mucho más su
estilo y se ve que puso mucho esfuerzo
en muchas de las escenas del manga
grande esto yo taron
ya todos saben que este es un problema
muy recurrente en toda la serie diciendo
esto dudo que algún día cambie las
escalas de poder hace tiempo que se
fueron a la [ __ ] en esta saga toyota
no trató de arreglar un poco esto
evitando crear personajes ultra
poderosos de la nada y cambiándolos por
personajes con un nivel de poder más
equilibrado y basado más en habilidades
pero aún así no se salva de tener
momentos que dejan un poco confundido
[ __ ] es que en el momento del manga
estás viendo como q pelea 1 1 contra
moreau y después ves como un personaje
cualquiera le está causando el problema
aún en su transformación de dios
afortunadamente al igual que con la
mayoría de cosas que ya he dicho este es
un problema que se da cada vez menos y
poco a poco se ha tratado de corregir
pero no deja de ser raro que no siempre
es prisionero le rompan la cara a los
personajes que en el arco anterior vimos
cómo acababan con siete universos
desde el mismo instante en el que
comencé a interesarme por la historia de
moró tuve un temor constante de que el
final de la saga no fuera tan bueno como
el resto de la historia y
desafortunadamente no lo fue
miren yo me conformaba con una buena
pelea y que vegeta fuera el que
derrotará a moro y ya pero no en vez de
eso me dieron un [ __ ] susano por favor
que se est
esta saga tuvo una gran oportunidad de
devolverle algo de protagonismo vegueta
y dejar que sea él quien derrote a moro
pero nuevamente todo recae sobre los
hombros de goku y está bien si quieres
que escuche al ganador de la pelea final
por décima octava vez está bien pero el
desenlace de la pelea final pudo haber
sido mucho mejor no sé qué [ __ ] una
pelea en equipo con vegetal undertaker
laden out cualquier cosa pudo haber sido
mejor que el susano de goku pero al
final cabo detrás con bolt super bien
algo tenían que equivocarse
[Música]
durante todo el manga de dragon ball
super hasta ahora con tarot se encargaba
del dibujo y el 'todopoderoso' akira
toriyama se encargaba mayormente de la
historia y del argumento de la serie
pero la saga de moró es la primera vez
que se le permitió a toyota no
involucrarse con el argumento y estar al
mando de la historia pues aunque aquí ya
lo estaría supervisando toyota pero
podría darse ciertas libertades y crear
una historia original y creo que hizo un
gran trabajo yo adoro akira toriyama
pero en ocasiones su estilo se siente
algo repetitivo en dragonball y toyo
taro al ser tanto su asistente como un
gran fan de dragon ball quiso crear una
historia que no se accionaría a los fans
de la historia y se nota que le puso
mucho esfuerzo esta saga no fue perfecta
pero su primera vez estando al mando de
la historia y no lo hizo para nada mal
creó una de las sagas más memorables en
dragon ball super y pudo hacer que
muchas personas recorren el interés en
el manga además me alegra mucho que por
fin estén confiando a toyota no mucho
más que solamente el dibujo dándole la
oportunidad de involucrarse más en la
serie
[Música]
siempre he tenido un problema con las
transformaciones en dragon ball super
pero cuando llegó el trans tinto todo
parecía que cambiaría se tomarían con
más calma esto de los pavor a 2
se declaró durante todo el torneo del
poder no paraban de decir que
no era lo mejor y que era algo que
incluso para los dioses en algo difícil
de alcanzar así que en mi ingenuidad
pensé que le darían el respectivo tiempo
para desarrollar el mejor tiempo
pero no de inmediato en la siguiente
saga goku ya lo domina no pudieron
esperar ni siquiera una sola saga antes
de hacer algo q aún más roto y
permitirle que controle el ultra
instinto ahora estaba mejor que aprender
a controlar primero la señal en esta
saga y que ya poco a poco en el
siguiente arco aprender a controlar el
ultra en ciento perfecto pero para que
una técnica que ni siquiera los dioses
de la destrucción pueden controlar a la
perfección y boku ya la puede gustar a
voluntad desde el torneo de los
universos cuando se introdujo esta
transformación sé que a todos nos
encantó el tránsito pero ahora ya que
goku lo puede usar cuando él quiera va a
perder la gracia y se va a convertir en
una transformación más del montón
hubiera sido mejor que guardan el
misterio lo tres ciento un poco más pero
no pueden dejar pasar una saga sin qué
cocu dominar a una nueva transformación
creo que de lo que más me gustó en la
saga del prisionero galáctico fue que no
solamente hicieron una nueva historia
sino que se tomaron la molestia de hacer
que esta historia se relacione con
aspectos que ya habíamos visto antes en
la serie y así pueda expandir el logro y
la historia de dragon ball algo que
siempre me molestó en super es que sus
sagas no tienen nada que las conecta
entre sí comenzamos la saga de los
dioses luego peleamos contra fiestas
porque porque si luego de la nada nos
bajamos a otro universo por qué por qué
sí y luego peleamos con el gokú oscuro
porque porque creo que ya entienden el
punto al no tener ninguna relación
aparente una saga con la otra no se
siente como si las historias que vemos
tuvieran lugar en el mismo universo sino
como historias separadas siendo lo único
que las une el hecho de que aparecen los
mismos personajes pero con la saga de
moró pasa algo distinto pues no solo
llega un villano poderoso de la nada
antes de comenzar la saga se nos cuenta
su historia e incluso para hacerlo más
interesante se une su historia con un
concepto ya existente en dragon ball
como lo son los caidos no sólo crearon
amorós sino que lo usaron como un medio
para expandir el universo de dragon ball
primero trajeron de vuelta un personaje
del que nunca supimos mucho a grado cayó
en sama y a través de morir su rivalidad
nos explicaron la historia de ambos
personajes y su importancia y segundo
exploraron otro concepto olvidado que
dragon ball z nunca exploró el todo el
planeta de lo sagrado siendo no sólo fun
service sino que la inclusión de los ya
dará ayuda a la evolución de vegueta en
este arco y a redescubrir una
civilización que también ayudó a que la
historia progresar y así con pequeños
detalles el arco de moró recordó que era
con bolt no sólo toma lugar en la tierra
y en amacuzac sino que toma lugar en un
vasto universo en el que hay muchas
cosas que aún no hemos explorado y son
esos pequeños detalles que hicieron a
esta saga mucho más interesante de ver
en general el arco de moró es una
historia mucho más completa y mejor en
todo sentido tiene muchos aspectos malos
por supuesto pero se ven opacados por
todas las cosas que la historia hizo
bien nos dio una buena historia un gran
villano y desarrollo a su universo y
estos personajes mucho más de lo que
cualquier otra saga en super lo había
hecho fue una sorpresa ver que esta saga
fuera tan buena y ahora con otra
película ya anunciada y con un nuevo
arco continuando en la historia sólo
espero que la serie siga mejorando cada
vez más
y tal vez darle un poco de protagonismo
y cocu ya no sea tan [ __ ] nadie me
dice que tan imbécil puedo ser
[Música]